we are the miracle dolls and we started
the Native American youth music program
and we know this will create change in
our community this last song we did was
called sweet grass waters life and it's
just talking about we only have one
earth and we got to treat it better
[Music]
it took us like three months to write
and I think we've spent a lot of time on
that song just you know crafting it we
spent a lot of time too because we are
pedasi water Buster clan our people
lived along the Missouri and to see the
effects what the oil has done to our
community people could get cancer you
know the water is no longer good to tree
[Music]
mean des made the Native American youth
music program because we knew it would
bring healing you know as it did for us
it changed our lives completely yeah
just keep doing that there is a high
rate in suicides amongst the youth in
our community it'll break your heart you
know if you travel through the
reservations and you hear these stories
and that's why we created this program
so it could change what's going on in
this community we are at Sherman Indian
High School we got ten guitars donated
to this school for for a class a guitar
class and we're gonna teach class right
now yeah strum the chord with me guys
with that same pattern our goal is to
get guitars and all reservations because
we know how much has helped us through
the hardships of our community you could
connect to a song and you know it lets
that emotion out it's a it's a form of
therapy also if somebody gets so angry
because their dad gets drunk or whatever
they could go to the guitar and release
that anger into their instrument or
they're feeling sad and they need an
outlet they could put it into a song and
then they could go out in the public and
release those emotions a lot of kids you
know especially in the Native American
community need some kind of form of
expression because they're just going
through so much there's a lot that comes
with what happened from the past from
the massacre of our people that that's
trickled down to our families I call it
a historical trauma it's something that
we could get through through some sort
of outlets therapy music
we traveled through the US through all
the reservations playing shows and we
seen the need there it wasn't really a
choice I don't feel like it was a choice
I feel like it was a necessity it's like
family you see someone in your family
hurt you're gonna go make a difference
me and des agreed even if for old people
we're going to get guitars so every
reservation
[Music]